Abrams: Hi, my name
is Jacob Abrams.
I'm a director of engineering
at Glu Mobile.
I'm here to show you
my Android application.
It's called Bonsai Blast.
It's a simple game.
We have a couple
different modes:
Survival and Adventure.
I'm gonna show off
Survival here.
Just press here
to go into the game.
It's a simple puzzle game.
It has many different levels
with the balls.
You match three balls,
they explode,
and they don't get
any closer to the end.
When it gets to the end,
it goes down the drain,
and you lose.
So here I am.
I'm just matching
these three colors,
trying to keep the balls from
getting too close to the end.
So I was just playing
Survival mode.
Now I'm gonna switch over
to our other mode,
Adventure mode.
Just bring up the pause menu,
click right here,
and withdraw from this mode.
We're gonna just go right here
into the other mode,
Adventure mode.
And so in this mode,
you get to unlock
all the different levels
and features that are available
in Bonsai Blast.
So we'll start out
on this level three right here.
All right,
so the technique here
is to get as many points
as you can
and fill up the bar
over here
at the top of the screen.
So there I got a big bonus,
'cause I just unlocked
a treasure chest.
Uh...
at this point, I'm simply
matching three
and trying to gain
as many points as I can.
So my company, Glu Mobile,
we decided to develop
a game for Android.
We picked a game
called Bonsai Blast to develop.
It takes advantage of a lot of
the features that Android has.
It has a touch screen interface.
It has a high frame rate.
Lots of sound effects.
And, uh, it's a fun game
to play.
But it's a difficult game
to master.
So how we developed this game,
we basically ported this game
from J2ME.
So it's got a MIDlet class
and a canvas, just like J2ME,
but we switched that
to an activity,
which is like a MIDlet
and a view which is like
a canvas.
Uh, that part
was pretty simple.
Then we moved on
to working on things
like CPU usage.
Uh, one of the advantages
of Android
is that it has a simple
tick interface.
Basically, we just used
the OnDraw method
to do our threading.
We called invalidate
in gameplay
to increase the performance
to the absolute maximum.
Uh, when you're in a menu
that has animation,
we use post-invalidate delay
to slow down the frame rate,
but free up the CPU
so it's not killing
the battery,
because this
is a mobile device.
When you're in a non-static--
when you're
in a static screen, we use--
uh, we turn off
the constant repainting
so that the hand set's
not draining the battery,
and we only respond
to user input.
And that way,
the battery life is kept
to an absolute maximum
while you're playing our game.